esta es la reacción de su información
del benceno aquí tenemos el benceno y le
agregaremos un poco de ácido sulfúrico
como productos formaremos ácido benceno
sulfónico y agua como la reacción está
en equilibrio podemos cambiarlo usando
diferentes concentraciones de ácido
sulfúrico por ejemplo si usamos ácido
sulfúrico concentrado provocaremos que
el equilibrio de la reacción sea
favorecido hacia la derecha es decir que
tengamos más ácido benceno sulfónico
pero si usamos ácido sulfúrico diluido
entonces tendríamos más agua lo que
cambiaría el equilibrio hacia la
izquierda echemos un vistazo al
mecanismo aquí tenemos dos moléculas de
ácido sulfúrico y una de estas moléculas
funcionará como un ácido
y la otra funcionará como una base
digamos que la molécula de la derecha
funciona como un ácido donar a un protón
y la molécula de la izquierda funcionará
como una base aceptará el protón este
par de electrones tomará este protón
dejando estos electrones con el oxígeno
dibujemos el resultado de esta reacción
ácido base tenemos azufre unido con un
doble enlace a estos oxígenos del lado
izquierdo tenemos un grupo o h
y del lado derecho hemos proto nado a
este oxígeno tiene una carga formal
positiva y la otra molécula de ácido
sulfúrico perdió un protón nos ha
quedado la base conjugada que es hs o 4
menos
aquí tenemos esta carga negativa en el
oxígeno si seguimos a los electrones
estos electrones se quedaron con el
oxígeno por eso es hs o 4 - y estos
electrones en rosa formaron este enlace
con el hidrógeno tenemos una molécula de
agua escondiéndose por aquí es un buen
grupo saliente estos electrones se
moverán hacia acá empujando a estos
electrones que se irán junto con el
oxígeno nos queda h2o como nuestro grupo
saliente sigamos a los electrones
digamos que estos electrones en azul son
los que se movieron hacia el oxígeno y
también nos ha quedado este azufre unido
con un doble enlace a un oxígeno por
aquí y otro por acá
también está unido con otro doble enlace
a un tercer oxígeno este oxígeno aún
tiene un hidrógeno y un par de
electrones libres lo que le da una carga
forma al positiva sigamos a los
electrones digamos que estos electrones
en color amarillo se movieron hacia acá
esta es la versión pro tonada del tri
óxido de azufre y el azufre es la parte
electrónica si pensamos en que el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
azufre entonces podemos dibujar una
estructura de resonancia estos
electrones en amarillo pueden regresar
al oxígeno dibujemos lo que nos queda
tenemos a este oxígeno con dos pares de
electrones libres y como le quitamos un
enlace al azufre ahora tiene una carga
formal positiva este es nuestro electro
filo podemos usar la versión de la
izquierda o de la derecha no hay
problema el azufre es deficiente en
electrones para las dos estructuras de
resonancia usemos esta versión y para la
siguiente parte del mecanismo dibujemos
a nuestro benceno
y por acá voy a redibujar la versión pro
tonada del so3
tria óxido de azufre
ya sabemos que el azufre es la porción
electro física entonces tenemos a estos
electrones bi que funcionarán como
núcleo filo y atacarán al electro filo
es decir al azufre y estos electrones se
moverán nuevamente hacia el oxígeno
mostramos el resultado de este ataque
núcleo físico ya teníamos estos
electrones pib y este hidrógeno ahora se
ha formado un enlace con el azufre que a
su vez se une con un doble enlace a dos
oxígenos y también está unido a un h
justo aquí
nuevamente sigamos a los electrones
estos electrones py en rosa funcionaron
como el núcleo filo y formaron este
enlace entre el carbono y el azufre pero
como le quitamos un enlace a este
carbono
ahora tiene una carga formal positiva
este es nuestro carbó catión y podríamos
dibujar las estructuras de resonancia
pero para ahorrar tiempo
esta estructura puede representar a
nuestro complejo sigma así que el
siguiente paso en la sustitución electro
física aromática es la de protón acción
de nuestro complejo sigma entonces
pensemos en el agua funcionando como una
base este parte electrones libres tomará
a este protón dejando a los electrones
que se moverán para restaurar el anillo
aroma
dibujemos el resultado de eso
hemos reformado el anillo aromático y
claro tenemos al grupo so3 h
saliendo del anillo
sigamos a los electrones
estos electrones en azul son los que se
movieron para reformar el anillo
aromático hemos formado el ácido benceno
sulfónico como nuestro producto ahora
mostramos que el agua funcionaba como
una base que tomó al protón pero a veces
en los libros se pueden encontrar el
avión hs o 4 - funcionando como la base
y tomando al protón para regenerar el
catalizador que es ácido sulfúrico el
agua es mejor como base que el hs o 4 -
por eso lo hicimos así esta es una
reacción muy dependiente de las
condiciones de reacción por ejemplo en
lugar de empezar con ácido sulfúrico
para generar la versión pro tonada de
trióxido de azufre
empezamos añadiendo trióxido de azufre
como tal entonces aquí
tenemos a nuestros oxígenos unidos con
un doble enlace al azufre
y si añadimos un poco de ácido sulfúrico
el ácido donará un protón al tri óxido
entonces en el primer paso este par de
electrones se queda con el protón
dejando estos electrones con el oxígeno
esta reacción ha sido base nos da la
versión del tri óxido de azufre protón
ado sigamos a los electrones estos
electrones son los que tomaron al protón
y formaron la versión proto nada y
también nos queda la base conjugada del
ácido sulfúrico hs o 4 - y esto
reaccionará exactamente como ya lo hemos
visto así que no importa como obtengan
su trióxido de azufre esta es otra forma
de hacerlo y si empiezan con el trióxido
de azufre el equilibrio de la reacción
se irá
hacia la derecha dibujemos eso
rápidamente
hacemos reaccionar nuestro benceno con
ácido sulfúrico
pero esta vez añadimos un poco de
trióxido de azufre el trióxido se añade
al anillo aromático
y por haber añadido el so3 extra
obtenemos una mayor cantidad de nuestro
producto les he mostrado al s o tres
proto nado funcionando como nuestro
electro filo en el mecanismo pero el
agente de su formación debe ser
solamente so3 y no s o tres proto nado
aunque también depende de las diferentes
condiciones de la reacción así que en
los libros se encontrarán con diferentes
mecanismos para la subsanación pero
obviamente usen la que su profesor les
pida en el examen en este vídeo yo les
he mostrado algunos ejemplos